what's the situation in which a panic
attack is useful you start suddenly
feeling like your heart is pounding you
start getting shorter breath your
muscles tighten up you feel like you're
maybe going crazy and you've got to get
out of there wherever you are so that is
a perfect Suite of things to get you out
of life-threatening danger such as a
fight flight response a pre-programmed
emergency response but why would it go
off when it's not needed
I saw a quote from Robert Wright's why
Buddhism is true which says humans are
designed to be effective not happy how
accurate do you think that is
that's so sad one of the first articles
that I wrote is why happiness is so
elusive from an evolutionary Viewpoint
and everybody wants to be happy
everybody tries to be happy there are
all kinds of businesses and
professionals and therapists who help us
be happy and it's not working very well
and there's a very specific answer is
that the total damn system is not
designed for happiness it's designed as
Robert Wright knows all so well for
maximizing Gene transmission what a
[ __ ]
I joke about it a little bit but I think
it's a terrible traumatic awful thing
natural selection doesn't give a fig
about our fitness or or about our
happiness and so a lot of people are
just wandering around all the time
miserable because the system is shaped
to don't go with them to do stuff that
is not in their interest it's in their
genes interests and
it makes me a little pessimistic
sometimes about you know the idea we're
all going to be happy if we only do the
right thing and think the right way you
know on the other hand that way of
deeper thinking I'm so glad you
mentioned Bob Wright because I'm very
impressed by him and his work but he's
right desire is the problem right
um we all have all these desires and
none of us can satisfy all of them and
it's all built into the design
desire is a contract you make with
yourself to be unhappy until you get
what you want that's from Naval ravacant
you know I don't buy that desire or
something it pushes us to do stuff
that's good for our genes and it doesn't
matter what we accomplish as soon as we
do it wants us to do something more and
so there's no winning that particular
one the hedonic treadmill and all that
I was talking to a couple of friends who
were recently on a very big podcast over
here in Austin and one of them mentioned
that he was fearful of gold medalist
syndrome which I wasn't familiar with
but I went and learned about afterward
which is after you've completed the
crowning achievement of your life's work
well what what do you do next what
happened what happens after that
so actually I've been I wrote only a
little bit about this but I'd like to do
more about it but it seems to be there's
something built in that after a great
success we always feel down and it's not
just winning a gold medal it's just you
know getting a paper done you know or or
doing your podcast afterwards we always
feel low why
and and there's a bunch of psychology
about this so opponent processes the
technical name
um but it seems to me that that's
probably necessary to keep us from
flying off into mania
I mean to stabilized mood you got to
keep it from getting into a positive
feedback mood where success made you
feel better which makes you feel more
mood and I mean that's what happens with
Mania right uh you succeed at something
you start flying off and you get
succeeded more and everything seems
great until you're you know in the
hospital or something I think it's much
better for the system to be programmed
to just bring it down quite promptly
after some ground success
is it the job of humans then if we are
permanently stuck in this vacillating to
an upper bound of happiness that we is
inevitably going to be brought back down
by our hedonic adaptation
how do people avoid just being
nihilistic with that how do they think
well this is all futile what's the point
in even trying to do anything even if I
make myself happy it's going to be
pointless because I'm going to be
brought back to Baseline within the next
three days
you know we feel happier when we
accomplish things that we want to do and
you know there's one little quote from
my book that's uh gets that's retweeted
every week by somebody for the last year
and the gist of it is that what makes us
you know gives us pleasure is not
actually accomplishing our goals and
what gives us happiness is making
progress towards goals and getting there
is not such a good thing but making
progress towards a goal this means you
got to have a goal of some sort not
something Grand necessarily but fixing
dinner you know or or having a fun
podcast or getting your Yeti microphone
to work
um our life is just consumed by all of
these little goals that we are all in
competition with each other
um but but that's the problem isn't it
um there are so many things that we do
and most of them around competition with
each other and if you want to be a
superstar most Superstars are really
focused on one thing to the exclusion of
other things and this is not a balanced
life
but it is a route to stardom
and this this is a problem especially on
this age when everybody's trying to be
super duper on the web
um it's just not possible to be the best
and to have a balanced life I don't
think maybe some people seem to pull it
off but I think it's very the the those
people that are able to be elite at what
they do and have a balanced life are
significantly more rare than the people
that are Elite to what they do who by
Design are incredibly rare and a perfect
example of this is Tiger Woods did a
charity golf game where he was with I
don't know Jared Leto or Brad Pitt or
someone it wasn't but somebody like that
right and they're walking around the
golf course and because it's for a
charity game uh they were lapel miked up
for the entire time and Rory McIlroy as
well uh who's a British player he was
there too and the Mike was capturing
what they said and you usually don't get
to hear what the player is speaking to
his caddy about right throughout the
most of the game obviously and um you
got to hear hear the difference in the
way that tiger approaches his game with
the way that Rory approaches his so as
they were walking around tiger and his
partner and he's some guy right maybe he
plays a bit of golf or whatever but he's
not a pro and Tiger's talking about okay
so you're gonna notice that the Fairway
is going to fall away a little bit to
the right here you're gonna have to open
the face a little bit I'm I really don't
want you to go for too much of a high
Loft Club because we've got this
humidity in the air and a blah blah blah
and then it cut to Rory McIlroy and Rory
was asking this guy who's like look I I
just can't agree with you that Domino's
is superior to Pizza Hut I I simply am
unable to oh he was talking about his
favorite sort of Peter or something like
that and you see that really made me
think about Rory as an incredibly
singular individual somebody that's able
to turn it on and able to turn it off
even during the game and I'm sure if it
was the PGA finals and whatever whatever
he's gonna feel a lot more pressure but
in that moment even the most relaxed
game knowing he was miked up tiger
couldn't swim switch it off
yeah yeah you know there are different
ways of doing things there's Zen In The
Art of archery you know where you know
if you're really really good your lower
brain takes over you don't have to think
about things quite so much but then
there are other people who are always
analyzing and there's different ways to
get there
why does the capacity for low mood exist
at all
oh you pushed one of my buttons I know
you'd asked that
um I mean first of all let's just pause
for a second it doesn't have to be there
right uh natural selection could have
shaped us to feel pretty good all the
time and not to have all these moods
going up and down and sideways
um Why didn't it do that so we have to
ask first of all why have mood at all
and the answer is that there are good
times to do things and there's bad times
to do things and sometimes a little bit
of investment will give you a bid payoff
and sometimes a big investment will get
you nothing I think about my ancestors
for the last thousand years on a tiny
island in the North Sea off the coast of
Norway and I every once in a while
imagine one of them that was very
optimistic a few hundred years ago
turkey off in February going off and
saying I can find some berries of food
out there and you know of course there
weren't any ancestry like that there
might have been somebody like that but
they died in the snow and they didn't
pass on any genes the one who was more
pessimistic sensibly and and just didn't
think that things were going to be all
great all the time did better
now in Modern Life of course we're not
foraging for berries nearly so much most
of us we're in Social exchanges of all
kinds and we're trying to look good for
other people
um but it's very tricky isn't it because
on the one hand we want friends and the
other hand we want status and we can
only have so much time and so many
friends and it's all very complicated I
mean we're basically foraging for social
resources and sometimes it goes well and
sometimes the more you call somebody up
the less they want to talk with you
um so there are people who don't have
any low mood in that circumstance
they're really annoying you know because
they just keep going and keep going and
keep going I mean for all of these
emotions Chris I think there's less
attention paid than we should to people
who don't have enough low mood
people who don't have enough anxiety
and people with hypophobia and people
because you know it's not wise to just
keep going and going you're like an
anecdote uh from a talk I gave a camber
years ago for a positive psychology
group and I told him about how I thought
low mode could be useful in
circumstances where you're pursuing an
unreachable goal and it really needs to
disengage you from wasted effort and
taking risks that aren't going to get
you anything
and there was definitely silence in the
room with all these famous professors
and you know their whole thing is
positive psychology and I'm saying hey
negative stuff is useful
um and then
um they looked at each other and they
looked at me and I was kind of thing
what do I say now but I'm a psychiatrist
so I know how to keep quiet sometimes
and finally one woman says you know
if I had more little Moon I would have
ditched that guy's 15 years earlier
and everybody laughed and it wasn't just
funny because you know there these moods
guide us in in momentary things and in
longer term things but the problem is a
lot of times with people who have
depression mood is trying to stop them
from doing something that they can
actually accomplish
um the the system seems to get broken
really easily and that's one of the
things those of us in evolutionary
biology try to figure out
it seems so ruthless that the
evolutionary set point that our minds
have been given for the last 150 000
years
is so mismatched with the world that we
see around us now the but you could
argue perhaps
the environment that we have created has
mismatched itself to our brains perhaps
we should be in a place where it would
be more adaptive to constantly be just
release a single tiger on the streets of
Manhattan and then that's going to
pretty much match everybody's anxiety
level with the degree of danger that
they're in
right right
so like we should pause here for a
second Chris and just Savor the fact
that life is good for a lot of people
for cold days and even weeks at a time
and that's astounding isn't it we should
just appreciate it I mean if we were
chimpanzees we'd be beating each other
on the fire on the head and wording away
from people trying to rape us and you
know it it's not a last life for
chimpanzees bonobos kind of have more
fun but you know sitting around quietly
and talking and enjoying each other's
company is not something they do
um I mean a lot of people have quite
stable satisfying lives and they're
moderately happy a lot of the time it's
just a miracle and I think just saying
it's culture doesn't nearly do it
justice I think we have to ask how
natural selection shaped us so that
we're capable of loving relationships
and guilt and and concern and and all
those kind of things it's not an easy
thing to explain
when it comes to some of the uh diseases
quote unquote is that people
pathologizing normal human responses
then
you know it's not so easy one of my
themes as you may know is that you
really have to talk with each person one
at a time to decide these things some
some commentators on the radio say oh Dr
Nessie you think little mood is useful
therefore you shouldn't treat it right I
say No in fact I'm sorry you even agreed
to do an interview with you because I
mean it's such a simplistic response
um but here's a big principle that I've
been just starting to write and talk
about Chris it seems to me that the
regulation mechanisms natural selection
shaped result in most bad feelings
coming from normal mechanisms but being
useless
so how can that be
um I mean the smoke detector principle
is one thing that we could talk about
another one is that we live in an
environment that's very different from
the one we evolved in another thing is
just bad luck another thing is that the
system is prone to real dysfunction from
getting into positive feedback loops
um and this is really bad for depression
and it used to be you'd have a bad time
somebody'd be mad at you something would
have and you'd go to your hut and then
you get hungry
and then you'd come out and there were a
bunch of relatives around some of whom
would want to help you nowadays you move
to a different city by yourself there's
nobody else there and you get in a bad
way and you go to your room and you shut
the door and you turn off the telephone
and then you tell yourself nobody loves
me because nobody's calling me because
your phone is turned off and you know
you don't send any emails it's a
positive feedback cycle
of A Sort that I don't think existed in
nearly that same way way back when
but now I'm starting to make stuff up do
we have data on that no no we just kind
of go on with our epidemiology comparing
people in modern countries we do not
know nearly what we would like to know
about what mood problems were like for
people in other cultures and other
states
it seems like the fundamental belief
held by most people especially people in
the more traditional side of the
Psychiatry realm is that if we feel bad
something is wrong
the only reason that's right something
is wrong but but not with the person
necessarily it might well be the
situation but let me I spent a year and
a half just studying emotions because I
realized I've been treating people with
emotional disorders for 10 years and I
didn't know why emotions existed uh so
after just studying emotions by the way
the leading Psychiatry textbook a
thousand Pages it had one half of one
page about normal emotions I mean this
is this is hopeless
um in the rest of medicine you see
somebody with fever you see somebody
with cough you see someone with vomiting
you know that those are useful responses
and you know what kinds of situations in
which they're useful so you go looking
for what's wrong
um so after that year and a half I came
to a very simple conclusion which still
hasn't it's catching on but not as much
as I would like
um instead of just asking about what's
the function of this emotion which a lot
of evolutionary types still do I think
the right question is in what situation
was this emotion useful
across our evolutionary history because
it's those situations that shape the
emotion and the regulation mechanism and
of course the situations are different
now than they were before that that's
one big thing but also a lot of those
situations can again put positive
feedback loops into play
and because if in fact you're anxious
and you start getting anxious about
being anxious off you are to the races
and a serious anxiety disorder
what's the difference between the
function and the useful in a situation
then give us an example
um you can find articles that say the
purpose of the function of anger is the
signal you're about to attack somebody
or is it the function of anger is the
signal that you're going to end the
relationship the person doesn't shape up
or it's a signal of anger to to say that
you are dominant in a dominance
competition or so you can make up six or
eight or ten of these kind of things and
they're all true kind of but they're all
ways in which anger could give a useful
uh advantage in one of those situations
a different way of asking it is in what
situations in what situation is anxiety
useful in what situation is anger useful
in a generalization I find really
helpful in therapy is to think if
somebody's really angry the first thing
I think of hey anger is really useful
when you think you've been betrayed by
somebody it's a signal that the person
that better apologize and shape up of
the relationship is over
and and that helps me ask different
questions it also helps me help my
patients to figure out that anger
actually sometimes is a useful signal
it's not something always to be avoided
that if that is it's possible uh to
potentially threaten to end the
relationship usually when people yell at
each other it's because they're really
dissatisfied but they can't end it and
walk away and it gets into a big mess
it seems like taking an evolutionary
perspective with this allows people that
are suffering with emotions which sadly
we all do to see them
with less shame
I suppose exactly oh thank you I'm so
you're glad you got to them I mean it
changed my work with my patients and my
patients view of themselves Chris
um I mean I kept that for 10 years I
told patients you have an anxiety or
mood disorder it's a problem eater with
your background or your brain and we're
going to give you the standard treatment
to fix it and and the responsive people
to that is oh my God there's something
wrong with me oh it's genetic
um that can't be fixed can it you know
the whole whole thing was I am a
defective person
and that that changes how you live and
how you think about yourself but once I
started saying you know what um the
responses you're having these anxiety
attacks they would be useful in
life-threatening situations and you're
having really unfortunate useless false
alarms in that system and then people
say oh well geez so there's something
useful about what I have as well I'm not
just a defective human being it's it so
changes the whole therapeutic
relationship and the person's
relationship with their symptoms and it
helps them to look thoughtfully about
whether the symptoms in their life now
might be meaningful and useful which
sometimes they are or they might be from
normal mechanisms but useless which is
the majority of them or whether they're
coming from a mechanism that just is
broken and isn't working right and I
think you can have a real conversation
with people about those Alternatives
instead of just assuming you've got a
broken brain you know we've got to fix
it with meds or you had bad
relationships with your parents and
that's what causes there's so many
assumptions that some therapists make
about where things come from and this
start this steps takes a step back
instead of asking about the causes for
this person's problem it asks why do we
all have systems that are vulnerable to
failure that that's the big thing why do
Minds go awry in general
I think that the way we experience our
own
lives our own inner world is very much
one of agency sovereignty the ability to
do things especially this has now been
laid on top with a meritocracy you are
your successes they're yours to Bear you
are your losses they're yours to bear as
well and when you combine this in a
world which is begun to Wrangle nature
in a way we can predict the weather we
can fly over oceans we have science that
can defeat diseases and stuff like that
I think all of that combined together
gives humans a sense that we should have
more agency over everything look the
reason that you're in low mood is
because you are somehow deficient in
yourself you have caused some
inefficiency to occur and this is your
cross to bear now it is your
responsibility to fix because it is only
you that can do anything in order to be
able to move yourself forward however
you have been born into a system that is
it's got all of these bugs in them and
some of these bugs used to be features
exactly and I think there's a lot to be
said for the novelty of our modern
circumstances making us all try to do
things we can't do so we're all failures
um but how much of that I mean is it
really true that there's a lot more
depression now than there was 20 years
ago that after that is pretty weak
actually you might have seen the New
York Times articles uh for the last week
um every day they have a new feature
about mental disorders and bad feelings
and how we're going to fix them all and
then the thing behind all part of it is
very thoughtful about hey it's not all
pathology I really appreciate that part
a lot of us talking about hey how can we
fix it for more people how can we have
SIMPLE therapies maybe the most recent
one today was about an app that you talk
to about your feelings and people
talking about how you can have an app
and artificial intelligence app to
psychotherapy for you maybe it's helpful
um but what I'd really like people what
what all those articles are missing
though Chris is any understanding about
why these emotions exist at all and why
they're prone to be dust regulated and
you don't almost want to stream a little
bit and say wait a second if you guys
were treating pain and nausea and
vomiting you would insist on some kind
of Investigation for each individual
about why those things are happening and
you're not going to stop people's cough
um just willy-nilly without thinking
about it because stopping the cough of
somebody with pneumonia might end up
killing them you're going to be
thoughtful about it so I just like to
see people understand that these
emotions can be useful at least for your
genes and that we should try one by one
to understand where they come from in an
individual in this particular instance
it seems like this a hierarchy or
multiple layers going on here which is
at the base layer humans have a capacity
to sense different types of mental
states that is something that has been
built into us and it was at one point
presumably adaptive or might be the side
effect of things that used to be
adaptive and the next level is this
particular the individual human here
what is it that their life is going
through or what is it with regards to
the way that they are relating to the
world which is causing this particular
emotion to come through so you have the
primer then you have the situation which
has caused it to happen and then on the
other side of that you have okay what
are we looking to do with regards to
treatment for this so that sort of
hierarchy there I I wish you could just
say that to all the Psychiatry residents
in the country Chris
um there's some people want things to be
so simple and it's very understandable
right they want everything to be a brain
disorder everything to be faulty
thinking or something but what you're
saying is to use what we understand
about why these emotions exist and how
they're regulated to try to figure out
on a case-by-case basis what's going on
and what options are best for helping
that individual person it's profound and
it's not something you can do in 15
minutes and making money a lot of money
off of it takes time and experience and
and so I'm not hopeful that we can
somehow make this the standard of care
but but I sure would like to see at
least all people who are providing here
um have this as in their tool kit trying
to understand why these emotions exist
and how they're normally regulated
go through some of the different reasons
about why we have this type of response
smoke detector principle and the
feedback loop and stuff like that let's
run through that and then we can have a
look at some individual emotions yeah
good I mean the smoke detector principle
I think may be my most practical
contribution to Psychiatry I spent you
know I was spending all my time helping
to run the anxiety disorders clinic in
University of Michigan George Curtis
started it and he and I helped to
develop it we were one of the very first
anxiety clinics any place and after 10
years I realized wait a second why does
everybody have too much anxiety it's not
just my patience it's me it's everyone
and then I tried to figure out why
telling people
um that things weren't really dangerous
didn't have any effect whatsoever
and my patients would go into a grocery
store 10 times and have panic attacks 10
times and I'd say you know it's safe I
got frustrated sometimes but then I
started thinking well what's the cost of
having a panic attack what's the
situation in which a panic attack is
useful and it you know that all I'm sure
all of our listeners have had something
like this at one time or another you
start suddenly feeling like your heart
was pounding you start getting short of
breaths your muscles tighten up you feel
like you're maybe going crazy and you've
got to get out of there Wherever You Are
so that is a perfect Suite of things to
get you out of life-threatening danger
uh Canon back in 1930 recognized us as a
fight flight response a pre-programmed
emergency response so why would it go
off when it's not needed let's think
about the cost maybe 100 calories but
now you hear a sound behind a rock at
the watering hole in Africa and you have
a stick instead of a iron spear should
you run well natural selection is shaped
a mechanism not just in us but in every
animal could do that calculation without
any calculus you know and it depends on
How likely is that there's a there's a
lion there and what's the cost if you do
run
and he's there and let's pretend you get
away scot-free what's the cost if you
don't run and he's there let's pretend
he just eats you
that's maybe a hundred thousand calories
oh wait the ratio 100 to 100 000 that's
a thousand to one and if you do the math
with what's called signal detection
Theory uh you realize that that means
that you should see whenever there's a
probability of a lion being there
greater than 100 000.
and that means that 999 times out of a
thousand you are panic attack will be
useless but normal
so that when I first did that I couldn't
leave my own calculation you know but
all of a sudden I realized oh wait a
second I've been misunderstanding this
regulation mechanism in my patients all
over the place now my patient came out
of the grocery store the tenth time
still having panic attacks and I was
able to say yep that's the way the
system is panic attacks are cheap on not
having a panic attack with real danger
is expensive but for you I suspect that
what you're really afraid of is your own
anxiety symptoms and they're ratcheting
themselves up in a positive feedback
cycle a vicious cycle and that too was
really helpful for my patients because
they realized that they were afraid of
their own symptoms and their symptoms
were causing anxiety and the anxiety was
causing more symptoms and off they were
to the races there were some patients
who said oh thank you that's all I
needed now I understand I'm out of here
don't need to see you anymore more of
them needed more behavior therapy or
medications I mean we use whatever works
um but it was such a revelation of me to
actually understand what the heck I was
doing uh when I was treating people with
a panic disorder
what about the consistent regrooving of
particular Sensations particular thought
patterns and emotional responses
well one I'm not sure what you're
getting exactly but there are also
systems that reset the threshold for
responding depending on your environment
so if every night you go to your
watering hole and there's a lion there
it's really smart for the threshold to
go down and for you to be much more
sensitive and not to go anyplace near
that unless you have a spear and three
friends and you can run home quickly you
have panic attacks go off so this is
fascinating though because then
the having a bunch of panic attacks
makes panic attacks more likely
if it makes the environment seem
dangerous and that's what's so when I
say that natural selection has left some
of these systems intrinsically
vulnerable to failure this is a great
example and it's really good to have a
system that readjusts the threshold for
anxiety based on how dangerous your
environment is but that makes the whole
system prone to go into a positive
feedback spiral and that leads to a
genuine serious disorder but you don't
get that consistent feedback spiral it
seems towards positive effect now maybe
a little bit more confidence or a lack
of fear but as you mentioned earlier on
confidence begets competence begets
confidence begets competence and then
you would have some person whose feet
couldn't touch the ground for the next
30 Years
right right you know I mean doing things
repeatedly and moderately succeeding at
them is good we know we have treated so
many hundreds of people with social
fears and it wasn't until I treated the
first hundred that I realized that what
they're afraid of is failing
they're not afraid of being in front of
an audience they're afraid of failing in
front of an audience and and doing
something silly so what's the right
behavior therapy exercise for that
I'm sorry you got to do something in
front of an audience it's a failure
um and and been making some mistakes and
being a podcaster like you are I'm sure
you're used to hey um I made a mistake
today and that's part of the game you
know it just happens and and on on we go
instead of feeling too bad about it and
worrying too much about it
um there's a famous newscaster who's
about to come out with his book about
his struggles with anxiety is it done on
the air
now someone else I won't tell you his
name yeah okay I'm sorry didn't done
Harden do a book didn't it wasn't he the
guy that had the panic attack live on it
or he was one particular newscaster that
had a panic attack and he did uh
uh
um it was a book about meditation and
this is five to ten years so this this
is another one and you know you bring up
this fact that we're in different
circumstances now this is a great
example and it used to be the biggest
group you'd ever see in human society is
30 people you'd be around a campfire
he'd say something stupid and somebody
would say what did you say and then you
say oh I never said that I didn't mean
that and you know then it's over
everybody's probably drunk anyway
nowadays you say one wrong thing and
it's recorded on podcasts and you lose
your job or you send the wrong tweet and
it's the end of your career
um that's unprecedented I mean the
amount of care and we're constantly
monitoring ourselves say oh be really
careful you don't say that which of
course brings it to mind right and it
makes it makes it likely
um so I think you know we're all on
camera or on microphone in ways that
were unprecedented and that does create
new pressures uh for self-control and
and that causes more anxiety and all the
rest everybody is I think did I touch
the nerve there no not at all in your
job and it's it's something that I've
had to work through a lot because I'm
very self-critical and I throughout the
show you know 530 iterations 540
iterations of doing this thing and if I
mess up if I
use the wrong reference if I bumble one
of my words if my pronunciation and my
diction isn't sufficiently precise it
will play on my mind once I finish up
and I think I must work on that I must
work on that that was that was not where
I want to be I should be better than
that and
the anxiety that you get around not
reaching that level is it it does sit
with you however I've found that
drilling it over and over and over again
allowing that to sit with me and going
look you I overall I was happy with my
performance I think what were the
contributing factors maybe I hadn't
eaten particularly well that day maybe I
wasn't sufficiently hydrated I hadn't
slept right I hadn't trained on the
morning perhaps I hadn't prepared well
enough for the guest whatever I've been
able to move myself away from it being a
label about me and who I am and more
into a assessment around my performance
in the same way that an athlete might
say look I I didn't quite get there on
the times today we need to look at my
nutrition we need to look at my sleep we
need to look at my recovery I really
think that there's a lot to learn from
treating our Pursuits in life the same
way that athletes do they seem to be
able to have more distance they
understand that there are all of these
contributing factors that create the
performance the outcome that comes on
that now it was interesting what you
said about um
the fact that everybody's basically 140
characters away from losing their entire
life in Korea at every moment and I had
a conversation with a friend who's also
a club promoter which is my uh how would
you say my upbringing as a businessman
and we used to run a bar crawl event
called Carnage in the UK and people
would buy a t-shirt the T-shirt would be
their ticket to the event and you would
go through five bars and then a super
Club at the end and there would be tasks
on the back of the T-shirt you can tell
this was before the metoo and uh sort of
social media era it would be um got off
with three randoms pulled a pig
um stole somebody's drink like just
Mischief stuff that people would get up
to but you would have 3 000 students a
night doing this moving from different
venue to different venue and we would
have this really wild orchestrated way
of because these venues would only hold
500 people until the last Club so you'd
have to move people in little groups and
there'd be Road Crossings and we'd have
stewards to stop the cars it was wild
that uh Larry loudy style of very loose
British Behavior which
was quite common and still is in some
circles has been completely eroded right
over the last decade and a half it it is
so different and I was having a
conversation with a friend he said dude
you know what it is I think that this
panopticon that we've got where the
Sword of Damocles is hanging over
everybody at every Point anything that
you do if you kiss the wrong guy or girl
on a night out previously 15 years ago
that would have been passed around as
rumor maybe between the people that
could have said it to each other maybe
they would have been able to text it
around or something like that but there
wouldn't have been any photo evidence
you could have denied it and after a
while it's not instantiated in the
multimedia 1080p way that now people are
so much more concerned about the way
that their behavior is going to be
instantiated online for the rest of time
it is not surprising to me that that's
the way that people feel
you know it's a whole different world
and we are ill prepared for it
evolutionarily
um I'm fascinated by the Paradox that in
one thing that came with Freud and
Psychotherapy is the possibility of
confidentiality
um prior to that kind of thing maybe
your doctor would keep things
confidential but there wasn't a study
you could tell somebody all of your
worst characteristics and and have some
confidence that they would keep them
secret sometimes that doesn't work but
therapists are really good and I'm still
not going to tell you about that TV
anchor who has anxiety because he didn't
give me permission but I'll tell you
afterwards because he's going to come
out with a book that I think is is
pretty good
um so on the one hand there's the
ability to get into touch with your own
deep anti-social and sexy and all kinds
of feelings and wishes that you never
would have told anybody
um if there wasn't the promise in Adam
andity and then conversely especially
with modern media it's the exact
opposite any tiny thing can be reserved
forever I mean everybody can look at me
these poor political candidates you can
you can do a gotcha on anybody yeah if
you have enough tape
um yeah yeah well I mean you see this
it's one of those uh byproducts I
suppose that you uh go through time as
somebody that puts things out on the
internet I'm sure that there's there's
papers or presentations that you've
given that if the wrong section was
clipped at the wrong time and then using
oh no don't don't go looking please
don't go looking precisely I know I know
but this is something that I have in the
back of my mind up until now there's
maybe what a thousand hours perhaps
maybe 1200 hours of content of me out on
the internet and there's some things
where I've put my foot in my mouth as of
yet this is not a challenge to the
internet but as of yet the The Smoking
Gun that unearths my secret bigoted
patriarchal CIS heteronormative
superstructure whatever it is that I do
that none of that's come about because
as far as I can see I don't believe any
of the things that would be distasteful
in that way
but my point being if you do anything
for long enough there is a non-zero
chance that you do say something that's
more than putting your foot in your
mouth maybe it's your entire leg and
we there's no
um
extra allowance for people that speak
more that gives them degrees of freedom
to get away with saying different things
so let's say that somebody says does one
video on the internet ever in their
entire life and somebody does
twenty thousand hours of content
throughout their entire life the person
that does twenty thousand hours of
content is much more likely to say
something however because you get to
take things out of context clip them and
throw them on Twitter
that is taken completely in isolation
and look I I try my best I just happen
to have said the wrong thing at the
wrong time that's not something that
people use so you were just saying Chris
about the fact that you're actually a
very careful person who reviews your
performances and tries to figure out
what went wrong and why it went wrong
just like another athlete might do and I
think that is the key to a lot of people
really being successful getting better
and better at what they do on the other
hand when we treated people with social
phobia as I was mentioning that what
they're really afraid of is somebody
else
no seeing them make a mistake
and so we have people so bad that they
can't go into the grocery store because
they're afraid of what the cashier is
going to say or if they're going to make
a mess up when they try to sign their
check these are really serious disorders
and so one of our first exercises is to
help them make mistakes on purpose and
see how people respond our favorite one
is to have them go into McDonald's and
order a big a Whopper
and then we have them go into Burger
King and order a Big Mac
and you know what happens if you do that
what happens is the guy says you don't
mean a Whopper man you mean a Big Mac
you want a Big Mac I think and he goes
oh yeah yeah and so people realize when
they make those mistakes that nobody
cares
nobody remembers
and and that's the kind of learning that
you get and there's no substitute for
actually making mistakes now if you're a
professional musician and somebody
Orchestra and you're trying out for
something you can't really afford uh to
make very many mistakes like that but
Horowitz you know Horowitz was terrified
by stagefront his career was wrecked for
quite a while because he couldn't go out
on stage he thought he was going to make
mistakes and finally he started making
mistakes and doing it
um this perfectionism was still there
but you just have to accept we're all
going to make mistakes
getting into some of the emotions what
is the reason for us being able to feel
low mood and depression
you know the capacity for low mood
exists because it's useful in certain
situations and the situations in which
it's useful most generically are
situations where you're spending a lot
of effort trying to do something that
isn't working
and if that's to happen I mean Eric
Klinger is a psychologist in Minnesota
wrote about this in 1975 I wish
everybody could read his work it's
profound and he pointed out that if
something isn't working the first thing
you do is stop and quit wasting energy
the next thing you do is try to find a
different way to your goal next thing
you do is try again with a different
strategy and if you keep trying again
with different strategies and nothing
nothing works then the system actually
turns off your motivation to keep
pursuing that goal and you do something
else a woman named Judah heckhausen a
German researcher moved to California
and she studied women who wanted to have
babies and they were approaching
menopause that's a bad circumstance
right now people really really want
something and they're not sure if
they're going to be able to get it and
I'm grossly grossly simplifying her
research but one of the outcomes was
that menopause happened for a lot of
these women and they weren't pregnant
where they devastated the rest of their
lives no once the possibility was gone
for many of them all of them said oh
wait
I can't have that anymore that's
unrealistic I'm not going to worry about
that in fact why did I want to have kids
anyhow they're very expensive they're a
nuisance you know all of a sudden once
you take that gold away I think I've
cured more people by helping them to
give up useless goals that I have
helping them pursue goals when I was
young I kept on telling people don't let
the depression get in a way keep trying
keep trying you've applied to graduate
school four times try fifth time
I realized I was young and naive and you
know utterly you know insensitive to the
real life situations of a lot of people
it was much better to try to realize
well there must be good reasons why you
have to keep trying to do something that
isn't working very well could we talk
about that and are there other things
you might want to do in life other than
this thing that is not going so well and
that kind of approach I found so much
more helpful and more respectful of
people instead of just encouraging them
to keep trying or give up it's just if
people are stuck in a bad situation I
call them social traps where you're
pursuing something you can't give up and
your mother tells you you have to go to
become a doctor I won't love you anymore
at least she indicates that no wonder
you're trying and trying and trying to
do that but there might be alternatives
for your life that'd be more satisfying
how would this have shown up ancestrally
you know if good question Chris
you know I don't think people were doing
as many long-term big deal things way
back when
there's no applying to medical school or
PHD programs or trying to become a world
famous podcaster
um you know so you know there weren't
things like that that was trying to get
nuts and trying to figure out whether
it's wise to go out looking for them or
not and trying to be helpful to other
people in your group and become a leader
of your group but Warfare once there was
Agriculture and storage of things and
and hierarchies and that's a whole
different circumstance but I think back
in hunter-gatherer days there weren't
any such huge big deal things as the
ones that we routinely encountered these
as in kids you know in college or not in
college trying to figure out what to do
with their lives it's a tough road
I mean I find the competition especially
to get into schools and stuff I mean
it's ridiculous it's so hard for kids to
try to be the kind of person and portray
it on paper that everybody wants to have
in their college because you're smart
and attractive and socially more
motivated in all the right things what a
lot of pressure putting on everybody and
you can see why some people just bag out
and say you know forget it I'm not
playing that game it's perfectly
understandable
what about you mentioned anxiety which
seems to be smoke detector principle
people urring on the side of negativity
as opposed to positivity with things
what about social anxiety is that that
mapped across onto status and esteem in
a group
so an interesting thing about social
anxiety is that we all have it and we
all seem to have too much I mean the
criteria make it so that you know five
percent of the population has it but
those are arbitrary I mean the majority
of people are nervous about standing up
in front of the group and and saying
something and for the good reason that
you might say the wrong thing or people
might think badly about you you know the
payoffs are saying something smart are
not as great as the penalties for saying
something dumb and so it's it's an
anxiety-provoking situation but here's a
question I started asking myself why do
we all care so much
what other people think about us and
that goes back to a much deeper more
profound question about how the heck did
we ever get these capacities for
Morality and guilt and committed
relationships in the the arguments and
evolution and evolutionary psychology
about the origins of altruism and
cooperation are long and remarkably
nasty for people and getting people
arguing about cooperation and goodness
and you see some of the nastiest
tendencies in in human human life it's
very ironic but I finally found what I
found to be a satisfying answer is that
Chris and the work of Mary Jane West
Everhart an insect biologist who is
trying to understand altruism way back
in the 1970s and and her argument starts
with sexual selection you know there are
extreme traits peacocks tails and that
kind of thing because hey the female
peacocks are choosing the male with the
best tail so those poor males have to
drag around those long dangerous
expensive Tales to get the best mates
it's just how natural selection works
but the point thing she pointed out is
individuals are competing not just to be
the best mates but to be the best
partner for other kind of things too
and I think that's that's what has
shaped our human capacities for
sociality that individuals who are
preferred as partners social partners by
other people and invited to join the
group were invited to be buddies or
invited to do things or cooperate on
things people who are preferred as
partners yet huge advantages even aside
from sex and we compete to be the kind
of person that other people want to be
with and want to cooperate with and this
creates really strong selection for
being helpful and honest and empathic
and a whole lot of other things that
make people desirable it creates its own
selection of force for being good
uh immediately when I talk about this
some people say yeah but people cheat
all the time yeah they do
um and you know people who were trying
to do the right thing often get taken
advantage of but that's just the price
you pay uh for for trying to do the
right thing and it's remarkable and
wonderful that the vast majority of
people basically try to be good most of
the time
they're very sensitive to what other
people think about them and they instead
of going to bed thinking about how can I
trick somebody into sleeping with me
they think oh my god did she
misunderstand my intentions and and did
she think badly about me because of the
way I approached her and people are so
sensitive and trying to
um make other people appreciate them
and and just to wrap up this one more
time I find this hugely helpful because
the the crude ideas about you know we're
all you know a bunch of selfish genes
trying to replicate themselves as fast
as possible I think that's a socially
corrosive idea and it's very hard for
people to get beyond that simplistic
kind of version to recognize how natural
selection can shape us to have
capacities for Morality and commitment
once you get that I think it changes our
view of evolution and human behavior
pretty profoundly would there not be an
argument to be made that that is still
selfishness acting in a selfish way that
altruism is you doing it in the hopes
that you will be able to get something
reciprocally down the line
but think for a minute about when you
know somebody invites you over to dinner
and you you have a nice dinner there and
then after
um you're leaving you say to them that
was a very nice dinner I think it
probably cost about fifty dollars a
person uh I'm gonna invite you over to
my house for a similar deal or something
you know that's not what we do we don't
want Partners who are trading favors in
simplistic ways we want Partners who
love us who care about us now it's
always a touchy business because you
don't want to get too out of balance uh
with people uh but you know John 2 be a
leader cosmidtes or leaders in
evolutionary psychology and they talk
about the bankers Paradox
um note Bankers are very eager to loan
you money so long as you have a lot of
money already and you have collateral
but when you don't have any collateral
they're not interested in learning your
thing
what you want is somebody who will help
you when there's no guarantee of a
payback when you're sick when you don't
have a job when things are not going
well and the amazing thing is that
that's possible for humans uh a lot of
us have real friends who care about us
even when we can't do anything for them
some people don't believe that's
possible that it's a certain cynicism
and I think a cynicism that sometimes is
generated by evolutionary psychology
that everybody is out for themselves
some level always not really I mean I
think social selection shapes capacities
for genuine algorithm and genuine
morality of course it's not present in
everybody and there's a lot of cultural
differences and you have to be careful I
mean the people who really overdo it are
Bernie Madoff types right generous to
everybody until you find out that the
whole damn thing has been a fraud for
decades
where I see or where it amazes me the
most that uh humans are able to
coordinate in the way that they do
without anybody actually forcing
anything on top of them is on the London
Underground so if you've ever been there
you'll see that there are these trains
going past an unbelievable speeds even
the ones that are pulling in to slow
down and all of these people are stood
within a couple of yards of certain
death
nobody pushes anybody over
no one
likes to do it but it
but it's nothing compared to shimbuku in
Japan if you go to Tokyo and you see
people in their Subways they line up in
a perfect line the right number of
people for each car and file in in an
orderly way
it's astounding and it makes the Brits
cues look disorganized when you go to
certain other places we are proud of our
cues Randy I will I will not have you
besmirch the good nation of Great
Britain's ability to stand in a line
behind each other I I was going to talk
about New York City
it's different there good yeah good talk
about the talk about the bad ones
and this brings us to culture Chris I
mean this cultures vary dramatically
and what works in one culture does not
necessarily work well in other cultures
and we adapt ourselves quite nicely
um when I get into a taxi cab around
where I live in rural Michigan I'm
always nice to go and give them a nice
tip and I know he's going to take me the
most direct route because if he doesn't
I'll tell somebody I get in a taxi cab
in New York City and I put in my GPS to
see if he's taken me around about way
and I you know it's just a whole
different
different culture
what about ADHD
what is the ancestral reason that we
would have developed the capacity for
this to uh be a phenomenon
so I just wrote a chapter for a book
that's coming up next week about
evolutionary Psychiatry
I think 27 chapters it'll be definitive
for some time you might find some really
good people to talk to us in in that in
that book it's the first big edited
volume and it's done by people from the
Royal College of Psychiatry I mean I've
spent my whole career trying to develop
this field and it's thrilling to see it
finally come through fruition this way
um
but my chapter
um starts off by saying that the biggest
mistake you can make in this field is
trying to assume that a disorder is an
adaptation and has some function and
exists for some reason
I think that's a terrible mistake in
adhdu is not shaped by natural selection
there is variation among people in their
degree to which their attention stays
focused or wanders
and natural selection certainly has left
us with some you know breadth of that
it's not like we all have the exact same
you know tendency to attend the things
for 10 minutes or no longer some people
can focus for hours other people you
know 15 seconds
um the main explanation for that in my
view is that in ancestral environments
it didn't matter that much
whether you could focus for a long time
or not
another answer going back to ancestral
times is that there are different
strategies for getting your food one is
to focus in one spot and just sit there
waiting hunting and another is to wander
all over the place trying to find food
you know this happens even for fruit fly
larva have you ever heard that story
there there are two kinds of fruit fly
larva there are Rovers and sitters some
of them sit just about in the same place
and they gobble up all the food right
next to them others Rove all around
trying to find food in different places
and this is these are hunting strategies
in general and some Hunters stay still
in the woods and other Hunters roam
around on the woods and these are both
viable ways of trying to find things I'm
going to guess that when you are in a
tribe and the tribe is pooling its
resources you're not just going to eat
for yourself you're going to eat for
yourself and your family and maybe some
of your friends families as well that
means that if you Randy happen to be the
ADHD
uh predisposition version of you and
you're going all over the place and I'm
doing a different strategy we get to
spread the risk of this well maybe the
actual this particular season there are
only a very small number of bushes but
these bushes have tons of berries on I
win another season they might be spread
a little bit more you win overall by
smearing this across a population level
you end up being able to hedge people's
risks in a much more effective way
very right if in fact these people are
relatives who share a lot of your James
that works perfectly well
even if they're not your relatives if
you can guarantee that everybody's going
to equally share the resources that also
works very well
but if whoever gets the most keeps the
most
and one strategy works better than the
other consistently
then that strategy is going to go away
um the idea that natural selecting can
shape traits that benefit the group at a
cost to the individual just doesn't work
it seems like it works it seems like it
should work but George Williams my
co-author for developing the field of
evolutionary medicine put it out to
everyone's surprise back in 1966 that
you know traits that make individuals
sacrifice for the good of the group
can't persist
because if some individuals do more for
the good of the group at their own
expense and have fewer Offspring those
genes are going to be selected out
pretty quickly
now the follow-up from that is I'm sure
you're aware is that bill Hamilton just
about the same time the wonderful
British biologist recognized that you
can do things that decrease your own
reproduction even and that can still be
selected for so long as there are
benefits to relatives who have the exact
same genes as you do including those
genes for cooperation what's an example
of that
um actually the anecdote that one has to
tell when talking about this is from the
famous socialist biologist JBS haldane
uh back in the 40s and someone asked
them at a pub uh would you sacrifice
your life for your brother
and he says no I don't think I would but
I would for two brothers
or for eight cousins
and that really says it better than any
fancy math I could do
um but this idea that you can ensure
that everybody in the group pulls for
the good of the group even at their
personal cost
doesn't work in general now human
societies we should note are different
than that because you know we organize
groups on purpose to do stuff more than
that there are leaders or groups who
often are trying to exploit not
necessarily on purpose but they're
trying to get the group to do what's
good for the group and by the way the
CEO of the corporation gets rich off it
um by encouraging cooperation and
enforcing cooperation some of my
favorite work on this
um is by uh
uh let's see Harvard aggren has done
some of it and Kevin Foster at Oxford
and they do work on cooperation in
bacteria
bacteria cooperating even different
species of bacteria they can do it but
the key to them doing it is that they do
things that enforce the cooperation
without a cost
and I think that is going to be the
principle that that really turns this
behavioral Ecology of cooperation into a
more sophisticated science if there can
be Costless enforcement
that leads to remarkably
um pro-social traits what's an example
of that
well if you um if you see somebody
throwing junk out of their car and you
call them on it and you say you know
what you're throwing junk out of your
car they might pull a gun on you so that
is not Costless enforcement if you can
anonymously text somebody and say this
this Yahoo is throwing junk out of their
car uh please stop them from doing it
that's that's Costless enforcement
um but really in every day and every way
we do Costless enforcement and the
easiest way to do Costless enforcement
is when somebody starts talking nonsense
you just say thanks I guess that's
interesting and then you walk away
you know what we mostly do with people
who are saying stupid stuff is just
ignore them so we vote with our
attention
yeah yeah and what people hate most of
course is you're not being paid
attention to
um and that's for good reason
I've just thought that we were talking
about how um multiple different types of
attention level smeared across an entire
tribe could be useful because it
provides people with varieties of
strategies to the same problem
right
it seems am I right in thinking that
ADHD now in the modern world especially
for young boys and and men that are
going through the education system is a
particular problem because there is one
very specific type of challenge that
they are facing therefore a multiplicity
of approaches in terms of their ability
to attention is one of the key resources
that they need and somebody that has a
higher degree of intention is always
attention is always going to be in a
better situation which means that this
smearing this range that we have is
actually a disadvantage for anybody
that's below the well anybody that's not
the 100th percentile but anybody that's
below the 50th percentile is a
disadvantage
this whole idea you're supposed to sit
in the chair for hours and learn stuff I
mean it's hopeless
um I can't we it's torture for B and for
a lot of kids it's just saves the
professional academic of many decades
you know I my attention span is pretty
short Chris and you know I keep shifting
from you know I've written papers on
Evolution and anxiety and cancer and all
kinds of other things you're not
supposed to do that you know you're
supposed to just do one thing and keep a
focus and I've been incapable of doing
that unfortunately I've mostly gotten
away with it but there's something else
interesting about ADHD that I've
recently thought about but not written
about and that is the drugs that you
that work on it I mean they're basically
amphetamines amphetamines increase Focus
so what else we know about amphetamines
well they're stimulating the
dopaminergic system the reward system in
the brain and in fact if you're out
foraging and you're looking for
something and you're looking for berries
um every time you find a big patch of
berries that dopamine goes off
and that dopamine gets you to keep doing
whatever you're doing because it's
paying off very well
and when the payoff Fades uh you move to
the next Bush and you start looking for
in all organisms of shaped to stay at
the right length of time at a foraging
patch and move on to the next one at the
right time to optimize their number of
berries or calories they get per hour
and it seems to me again there are
different foraging strategies
um getting every single Berry off the
bush not the best strategy getting the
first handful off the bush and looking
for another Bush not the best strategy
but there's a long way in between of
trying to figure that out and these
dopaminergic systems adjust how long you
stay at that bush leading me through the
project maybe some listener from this
podcast will take up I wish somebody had
done this long ago I'd like to turn
loose kids with a genetic predisposition
to ADHD and a lot of other kids in a
field picking raspberries and watch what
they do
do the ones who pick raspberries who
have ADHD go more quickly from one Bush
to the next bush
is it a foraging strategy I bet it is
and this would also lead to tests for
ADHD where you could have kids just do
foraging on a computer screen and see if
they jump too quickly from one patch to
the next patch
um and it's and also whether they can
adjust as the patch density changes
um and these are very sophisticated
mechanisms not just in us but in
bumblebees do it very very well they fly
to different flowers and try to assess
what a disc flower is worth it and as
the day gets cooler and it costs more
energy to forage and the flowers are not
having as much nectar they turn off
their foraging and go home at just the
right time and those that stay too long
or those that don't stay out long enough
they don't do as well and this is very
much like I mean there would be ADHD and
bumblebees or too much focus in
bumblebees nobody focuses on the people
who Focus too much in every single one
of these disorders you can have too much
or too little and this is another
implication of an evolutionary view that
we should be recognizing there can be
too much and too little anxiety there
can be too little low mood as well as to
a much slow mood
what were too much sorry what would too
little low mood and too little anxiety
be like what would that sort of person
be like what would the dangers be
well too little anxiety is pretty
obvious and Isaac Mercer called and I
have called this hypophobia uh these are
people who have a life-threatening
disorder I mean I mean on the edge of
the Grand Canyon and and you know
there's one group of us who's likely to
have this more than the other
I mean twice as many men as women fall
into the Grand Canyon every year
um and it's no accident it's because men
do wild and crazy and risky things and
this is another Insight that came from
evolutionary thinking it was very
helpful to me in the clinic and then
talking in general and now maybe I'm
going to say one of those things that
gets me in trouble Chris so you can see
maybe I can you can edit it out if I get
myself in too much trouble but I get
asked often why do women have more
anxieties than men a lot of people ask
well it might just be our culture or
might be the patriarchy or or something
actually
Mayo rats and chimpanzees and all kinds
of organisms take more risks and they
die young
and the answer is that they're competing
and doing competitive kind of stuff
um but why do women have more anxiety is
there something wrong with them
and here's the Insight no uh women have
just about to write them on anxiety
thank you uh men do not have enough
anxiety because natural selection has
shaped them to take more risks because
that has in the past given a
reproductive payoff on average
I had Roy bio Meister on the show and he
did a study about men crossing a busy
road at a Crossing before the light went
green for them to go over and the
difference in the distance from the most
the closest car to them
in the presence of women or without the
presence of women and the difference the
difference when there's women around for
risk-taking Behavior just goes through
the roof obviously and uh it's just it's
so blatant and and obvious
um did I he once says women could fix
this right if they if they stay away
guys all right okay just don't don't try
to cross the road
well no don't have sex with wild and
crazy risk-taking guys that would solve
the problem for the whole species well
the problem there is that's that's what
women are attracted to right that's what
they want yeah
well that that's too greater
generalization but we'll go back to the
simple thing
um women do not have no excess anxiety I
think on the average women have the
right amount of anxiety and men have on
the average hypophobia which is where we
were a minute ago they don't have enough
anxiety for their own good
yeah I um
I find the differences between the sexes
in terms of their mental makeup
fascinating did I hear you say
that by the age of 20 for every 100
women that had died 300 men had died
so this came from a project that Dan
Krueger helped me with at University of
Michigan I mean I there I was making up
one of my lectures on evolutionary
medicine one time and I was pretty sure
that men had higher mortality rates than
women because I'd just been visiting my
grandparents and in the retirement
community and and the tables are all
women they're they're no men and so I
wanted to figure out so exactly how many
years less life do men have than women I
thought seven years eight years I
couldn't find that number but what I did
find is the World Health Organization
database on mortality rates by age by
sex by culture and by decade going back
100 years it was gold so Excel and I
spent the summer in the basement
analyzing that and I realized the right
way to analyze that was not just to
analyze the you know mortality rates it
was to analyze the ratio of mortality
rates between men and women and the
question I asked myself starting this
off is for every 100 men aged 8 20 who
died this year in the United States how
many women are how many for every 100
women who die how many men are going to
die and I thought well you know men do
some wild crazy things maybe it's 120
men
then I looked at the data Chris
it was 300 men
and it wasn't just a USA it was present
in all of 20 countries that we studied
and even before puberty male mortality
rates are 50 percent higher for men than
women and the rate is still higher up
until age 80.
and it's also present for 19 out of 20
leading causes of death Alzheimer's
disease is the only one that claims more
women than men so what do we have here
first of all a quick caveat it's not as
simple as natural selection uh shaping
sexual competition between men there are
some very interesting chromosomal things
involved that may be relevant and
they're profound cultural variations as
well we did another study looking at
parastrika on what happened in Russia
when things opened up and and what
happened is male mortality rates went up
to five times higher
um there's probably a simple answer to
that and that's cheap vodka
um which is not not as dramatic as
something else but but the big principle
here is uh that like you say men and
women are different in ways that affect
their health profoundly
the chromosomal pen thing that you're
talking about there is that men on
Nature's play things is that that theory
that men are less costly to have
genetic traits being played around with
and many of them failed and some of them
are good
no it refers more generally to the fact
that women have two X chromosomes and so
if a gene is missing on one of them
they're still okay uh while men have
only one X chromosome which is why
colorblindness is much more common in
men than women uh it's just because you
know you don't have a backup copy of a
gene if you're a man again what I'm just
saying is grossly simplified because
there there are certain backups and and
it's very complicated genetically but
that's the general idea
ancestrally
why would we be given the ability to
have an eating disorder something like
anorexia or bulimia or
so it almost sounds like you're making
the big mistake right there Chris
um of trying to say that there's an
evolutionary reason for eating disorders
as an adaptation and some people have
said that some people said Eating
Disorders are actually a strategy uh for
getting mates or for regulating your
reproduction or something I'd heard the
second one I'd heard the reproductive
cycle like basically uh how would you
say primitive birth control
yeah Michelle survey wrote about that
back almost 30 years ago and at the time
it was these this is where we all
started in trying to understand mental
problems from an evolutionary point of
view and I'm trying very hard now to get
people to not try to figure out what's
the Adaptive value of Eating Disorders
I'm trying to help them to back up to
say what are the universal traits we all
share that make us all vulnerable to
eating disorders and now I think I can
make quite a good case with those uh
characteristic number one is we really
want to be attracted to the opposite sex
especially at puberty
and two we care about our partners and
what they look like their peculiarities
in modern cultures where everybody's
trying to emulate some ideal from you
know media and the lack which makes it
all more extreme
the next thing is that we believe we can
control our Behavior just by deciding to
and I think Free Will and the belief in
Free Will is a big contributor to eating
disorders because people think that they
can just stop eating for a few days and
lose weight
it never works there's another thing
that natural selection is built in which
is a a famine protection mechanism so if
you just stop eating for a few days uh
as far as your body knows you're
starving
and it gets you to do what you're
supposed to do during starvation which
is fine food as much food as you can and
eat it all at once
that's called binging and when some poor
person who's trying to lose weight and
doesn't eat for a couple of days
suddenly finds themselves staring at a
whole loaf of bread that they ate or an
empty gallon of ice cream they get
terrified because they have in fact lost
control they get frightened they're
going to lose control again not only
that if you keep doing that the body
resets its weight set point up a little
bit
because if you're in in an environment
where the food is you're radically
available it's good to put on a few
extra pounds so paradoxically this
attempt to lose weight ends up with
gorging and gaining weight which again
sets into process one of these positive
feedback Cycles the more you try to stop
eating the more you binge the more you
get frightened the more you gain weight
the more you try to diet and on and on
it goes again I'm going to pause and say
it's not as simple as this
and not everybody who died some people
diet successfully and do not get into
binging episodes but other people
um I mean it's not nearly that that
simple and they're a whole separate kind
of question is why some people get
eating disorders and others do not
um one of the leading psychiatrists and
evolutionary psychiatrist Riata bed he's
one of the editors of this book coming
out and he emphasizes uh that Eating
Disorders are more common in modern
cultures and ones with big media
presences because people get unrealistic
ideas about idealized bodies and they go
out trying to emulate them in order to
do make competition kind of things I
think that's basically right but it
doesn't lead to that leads to dieting
and you have to combine it with these
other things I've mentioned to get into
the positive feedback cycle that leads
to eating disorders but notice how
completely different this is than the
usual approach the usual approach says
what's wrong with this eating disordered
person's genes what's wrong with it
really life what's wrong with their
pattern of thinking what's wrong with
their brain a lot of work on genetics of
Eating Disorders in recent years and
they've actually found eight loci on the
genome that influence your risk of
eating disorders and if you put those
together with even those that aren't
statistically significant
you can explain some of the variants
about who gets eating disorders and who
doesn't all together all the genes put
them all together you can explain 1.7
percent of the variation what we're
spending tens of millions of dollars to
explain that and trying to blame Eating
Disorders on bad genes I'm sorry that's
nonsense we need to be trying to
understand these disorders in terms of
the mechanisms shaped by natural
selection and why they're vulnerable to
malfunctioning
what about schizophrenia and bipolar
this is something that I'm seeing
especially on Tick Tock talked about a
lot more at the moment it seems a little
bit like a social contagion of self uh
how would you say uh self-diagnosis
um
but
why do those come about why are they
even something that exists
and the right way to ask that is why did
the genes that cause those disorders
persist
and it remains a mystery Chris
um I mean this is something I've been
very interested in the last chapter of
my book and I have a big article in
Psychology today suggesting some
speculations of mine about this
um there's been a lot of speculation in
evolutionary psychology about maybe
schizophrenia is somehow beneficial or
maybe the relatives of schizophrenics
are shamans and they stay home with the
village and they get extra meetings or
something like that and that's
Balderdash you know the schizophrenia is
a really severe brain disease and and no
that that's irresponsible I think to be
going on like that but it is the fact
that on the average schizophrenic man
has half as many children as other
people schizophrenic woman also about 20
or 30 percent lower
that level of Fitness should select
against any genes for that disorder
really strongly really fast so you have
to ask yourself well why the hell are
they persisting in the genome that's
very tempting for people so they must be
doing something good
um I don't think so
I think the most likely explanation is
mutation selection balance mutations
happen they're only gradually selected
out the process of brain development is
very touchy and any little kind of thing
can make it go wrong but here's the
question I think has not been asked
enough Chris why does it go wrong in
that particular way consistently what
yeah why does it end up with with you
know auditory and visual auditory
hallucinations of voices why does it go
wrong in a way that you people think
everything's buddies looking at you why
does it go wrong and the way that that
people you know
um
imagine they can read other people's
minds and other people and that and that
says something about the design of the
Mind
um it's kind of like this is going to
sound really crude but you know your
auto engine has certain ways of going
wrong you can get a knock if you use the
wrong octane gasoline you can you know
things go wrong because of the nature of
the engine but and I think that's the
way we should be trying to understand
these dire diseases that there's there's
something intrinsically vulnerable
about the information processing system
of the mind that makes it vulnerable to
going wrong in that particular way
but now you're going to ask me to say
what I mean by that exactly and you know
I don't think it's going to turn out to
be anything simple I have speculated
that maybe natural selection has pushed
the system to a performance Peak because
of the great advantage of the social
abilities and language abilities and
intelligence just in the last couple
hundred thousand years
and my other new idea along these lines
is that we should be talking about the
similarity between these kind of
problems and all the problems that
resulted because we stand upright
you may be aware that we got all kinds
of problems because we walk upright we
have varicose veins we have hemorrhoids
we have hernias we have bad ankles we
have bad backs we have I mean there's
all these things that go wrong
because standing upright uh we're
adapting to it gradually evolutionarily
but natural selection has not been able
to fix everything because it's slow
and because not all these things go
wrong for all of us
um I'm giving this a new name actually
I'm calling these things
wrenching transitions in the transition
to walking upright is a is a wrenching
major transition because it changes all
kinds of things and when you try to fix
one of them it's able to screw up
another one in the process of making
that transition and my speculation is
that the wrenching transition uh from a
previous kind of social life to the
cultural and social uh
um ecosystem that we live in for the
last 100 000 years that that transition
is a wrenching transition for the
information process and system of the
brain and it ends up with something's
getting fixed kind of like your
hemorrhoids got fixed or your varicose
veins you get fixed at the cost of
something else uh leaving us vulnerable
but I'm going to emphasize once again
this is just trying to make some sense
out of something that is so tragic
um and it's very hard to understand
when it comes to depression anxiety
bipolar schizophrenia social anxiety all
of the things that we've gone through
how much of this do you think can be
laid at the feet of the modern world and
how much of this is over diagnosing in
moral Panic human
nature hasn't changed particularly much
over the last 10 000 years
so were we as anxious and depressed and
full of ADHD when we began the
Agricultural Revolution
or a different way of asking it
are the disorders equally present back
then and would things like ADHD even
cause much harm way back then
um in ADHD in particular is something
that you know probably was just a
variation didn't hurt you much uh back
then I do think people have always been
prone to some bad depression and bipolar
and schizophrenia and autism
and I'm not at all sure that those
things I think it's actually quite
unlikely that those things are vastly
more common in Modern Life
um I think those are more intrinsic
vulnerabilities but genetically and
because of the kind of feedback things
that we we've talked about
but it's really disappointing that we
don't have good data about this
um
and there's good reasons for it I keep
encouraging people anthropologists to to
go out and gather data but how many
people do you need to study to figure
out what the rate of schizophrenia is
um a couple thousands and you need
sophisticated diagnostic things
hunter-gatherer tribes are 30 or 50 or
100 people
um you really can't do it very well
there are good field reports for people
who have things that look very much like
schizophrenia and Hunter Gathering bands
some about bipolar disease and OCD as
well but this is an area where we
continue to do gigantic billion dollar
studies in modern societies and
investing even the pittance of that to
study hunter-gatherer mental health I
would pay off big time
how can this approach to evolutionary
Psychiatry be a little bit more applied
how can people use this today can they
ask them some questions that they think
would be useful to to get themselves
through this
so I've been a big stick in the bud
Chris some of my evolutionary Psychiatry
friends say Randy you got to talk about
how it's useful and I say wait there's
no special way of doing evolutionary
Psychotherapy it's a framework for all
kinds of psychotherapy it's it's not a
competitor with any other view it is a
foundation for everything we all should
be using it that said uh in an article
I'm writing right now I'm trying very
hard to say how a psychiatrists who
understand and psychologists to
understand the evolutionary reasons for
vulnerability can get better results for
their patients and find their practices
more satisfying though we started off an
hour ago talking about you know how it
changes the patient's view of their own
disorder and encourages thoughtful
consideration of whether their current
life circumstances contributing to the
problem or whether the problem is a
normal but useless response or whether
it seems more to be a product of a brain
that's not working right and that's the
foundation for everything uh for these
more behavioral disorders as you
mentioned for eating disorders
explaining how an eating disorder might
come about isn't a magic fix but it
certainly can help people from getting
into that cycle of dieting when they
know it doesn't actually help you lose
weight and knowing the positive feedback
cycle helps some people to understand
what's going on again Eating Disorders
are hard to treat and once you get into
them you're not rational about any of
these things so so just explaining
things to people is not a big help but
it's some help and it's very helpful for
the therapist to know what they're
dealing with and and where the origin of
these things comes from I think with
things like ADHD it leads to new
research projects like the foraging
project I mentioned and ways of
diagnosing ADHD using computer games
again I don't know if these things would
work I don't want to be it it's so
tempting to be overly confident in a new
field
and I I'm quite convinced that
evolutionary foundations can make sense
out of all kinds of things and mental
disorders that have been controversial
um but claiming that you know we're
going to make All Therapy a lot more
effective instantly
I'm really holding back from that
because everybody else already does that
we should try something different and
try to say that we have explanations
that people need to thoughtfully apply
to conditions to see if there's a way of
using them in practical ways
Randy nussey ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you do online where should
they go
you know my book is good reasons for bad
feelings it's written for a general
audience it has lots of case studies and
some of the examples that you've heard
here are in there and a lot of other
things are in there I also wrote it for
psychiatrists and psychologists because
if you write a big fancy academic book
and this book has 800 references but
they're in Tiny Prints so you never see
them
um but so this book is really for
General folks as well as them uh the URL
is
goodreasons.info or if you just put my
name to Google it'll take you there now
there's also the international Society
for evolution medicine and public health
and the Royal College of Psychiatry has
something called Epson evolutionary
Psychiatry a special interest group
um where you can get more information
this is all happening very fast Chris in
the next five years you're going to see
a huge flowering of evolutionary
approaches to Psychopathology and I
think the challenge will be helping
people to be critical appropriately
about it and get away from this
grandiose everything is good about it or
everything is bad about it and just
consider every hypothesis one by one and
be thoughtful about how we can bring
this whole new science to bear it's so
pathetic that animal behavior and
everybody else has been using
evolutionary biology for decades and
only now is it finally being recognized
as a basic science for Psychiatry and
psychology well I really appreciate it
the fact that you're pushing it forward
it's working and maybe you'll talk with
other people and help help us develop it
over the next few years great fun
talking with you Chris thanks Randy I
appreciate you what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]